[Music]
our old-school education system focused
on academic subjects we never actually
use coupled with a prescriptive style of
teaching and learning is woefully
outdated not only is it boring our
children to tears but it isn't preparing
them for 21st century careers as a
result more parents are choosing to
homeschool their children with the
number of kids educated at home rising
by 27% in a year some parents have even
resorted to teaching their kids
themselves because they feel their needs
aren't being met in mainstream education
there are better and more innovative
ways of preparing children for a future
as productive adults we need to allow
state schools to be more dynamic and
focus on specialisms youngsters could
actually become exceptional in high-tech
high in the US and our own Brit school
are great examples of what can be
achieved when you offer career and
skills related experiences on a project
basis rather than traditional classroom
teaching style more schools like these
would be a real game-changer and perhaps
means that actual intelligence has a
chance against artificial intelligence
[Music]
subjects we never actually use subjects
we never actually I would say maybe sort
of project basis rather than just
looking in I just refer back because
this is how we now deal with this boring
our children to tears so school educate
has to be fun does it has to be fun at
all times it should never be just a
degree of you're going to learn that
French verb when you enjoy something you
actually take it in more so teachers can
only do lessons at have fun I'm saying
you can do
sometimes not doing what's fun sometimes
your childhood much more interesting
we'd get a lot more out of our kids as
the examples I've given sure and just
lastly because you know you and I don't
believe we talked about home education
my concern and I understand why parents
are doing it I worry about home
education solely in this area which is I
probably learned more about myself
playing a pretty average rugby team when
we used to lose more games and and being
in that kind of environment where you
therefore the other 14 blokes that
teaches you a hell of a lot I don't know
I suspect some of that obviously not all
of it it's probably due to parents like
at the Burlington schools for religious
reasons because they don't want to be
taught gay rights and that worries me I
know from personal experience that you
can get a kid to some of the best
universities in this country by
homeschooling because you have the
one-on-one attention you need but it
doesn't what it doesn't develop is a not
only the interpersonal skills and it was
talking about the be the kinds of ideas
that help us to integrate in society and
preparing them to live in a secular
society you could end up at a top
university in this country and still
believe in all sorts of medieval
nonsense because your parents pulled you
out of school because they didn't want
you to become I'm great when it comes
the whole homeschooling homeschooling
debate I think we're on the same it's a
tough one because the problem is you get
into all sorts of areas in terms of
people's rights and and and when you get
into sort of religious territory that in
itself becomes quite hard to police as
it were but I believe that kids should
be school together
and I think that if we have more options
for parents than perhaps we could go
some way to
this and maybe if children are
home-schooled what you add is that they
have to spend one day a week at a school
maybe it's something like that Rachel
well I mean I've got mixed feelings
about this I'm concerned about this 27%
because I think the off rolling I mean
parents Haven kids out of school could
have different causes one could be
religious difference with the
institution and the other could be
unwillingness to pay the fines when the
kids don't turn out you know to hell
with the school I'll take care of it at
home but then how do you then monitor
that the home education is going on
track I've got a not a confession I'm
very proud that I was home-schooled by
my own mother for a couple of terms I
have even got from 1970s I was just five
when I looked at it in preparation to my
mother's flat to get this I did
fractions I did I mean my mother did
this and I promise you it was one of my
happiest very few happy childhood
memories no she was a brilliant teacher
it worked really well but then we went
into mainstream education and I'm
prepared to take questions because we we
were between countries and we didn't we
miss the start of the school year so we
didn't get how does your mom know what
to teach you you
okay you do not have to have an
educational qualification to teach your
children I have taught my children how
to turn on the VCR children let's just
hear from one of these amazing parents a
mother of seven femida Raman the
flexibility the ability to be able to
coach and role model one of the biggest
things that has stood out and a lot of
people have commented is the level of
maturity that the children have and
their ability to be able to communicate
with people of different age groups they
are their crack troops of parenting
that's not easy with our education
system for me in this country is the
obsession with standardized testing I
agree because what you then get is
around this table all of us will have
different abilities and skills and be
better at some things than others but
when you apply a set set of tests and
this is if you pass you're clever if you
fail you're stupid it's asking for
trouble and what I think goes on because
of standardized testing is you then have
schools who were obsessed with things
like their Ofsted really yeah then they
do what they shouldn't be doing in some
cases which why are we measuring only in
a single way and what you end up with is
children being excluded for various
different reasons and alienated you have
workforces that are not really fit for
purpose and you have a lot of children
that lack the basic gumption and
innovation and creativity to get on in
the way I completely agree and there's
actually there's a quote from Tim
Nichols who is the head of policy and
public affairs at the National Autistic
Society since this concern and research
shows that my parents are homeschooling
their children because their schools
aren't giving them the support they need
this is really alarming particularly as
schools have a legal duty to make
reasonable adjustments for children on
the autism spectrum homeschooling should
be a choice but for many there's simply
no
option so again this is why I think we
need schools that actually have
specialisms so you know the children
they are actually enjoying what they're
doing and we're preparing them for the
jobs of the future
have children and when I do I hope how
many positions take them out of school
ideally for a year and I would like to
take them traveling to experiences that
existed I'd love to do that I want well
it depends on how many children I'm
lucky enough to have but I would
probably say from the age of about 10
probably 10 11 controversial but I don't
really give a monkey's about exam
results it's not how I guess about the
school your children or child attend
well I would give a monkey's around how
my child would be engaged and taught for
me I want children who were
self-sufficient who have got confidence
who are creative who will be able to
collaborate with people interact with
people so when you talk about different
cultures beyond 2+2 is 4 the complicated
stuff we studied at school why do we in
the age of the calculator and beyond why
do we need to memorize when the
automatic tool and you buy a couple of
drinks and you give the young man or
woman and you're watching the pledge
coming up
me
[Laughter]
[Music]